congrats on the movie i thought you did
such a great job in it
uh before every interview uh before i
get into why i get to talk to you i
always ask a few other kind of questions
um so up first will be what tv series
would you love to guest star on
i would love to guest star on killing
eve
i'm like i'm deep into it right now into
the third season i'm about to finish up
but now it's like
savoring each episode i have left
completely
um what movie do you think you've seen
the most
i think i've seen
oh what movie have i seen the most
probably
whip it remember with elliott page and
kristen wiig and drew barrymore
100 that's my that's my like my rainy
day movie
got it what was the last time you did
karaoke and what was
what's your karaoke song the last time i
did karaoke was actually
at the cherry wrap party
and my karaoke song is nine to five by
dolly parton
got it is there video evidence that's
online of this or this is like a private
i sure hope not
i hope that there is no videos video
evidence of it
jumping into why i get to talk to you um
talk a little bit about uh auditioning
for this
and are you the type of person that when
you audition you always think you're
gonna get it or are you always like
i'm not getting it but let's just try
i'm always the i'm not getting this but
let's just try
um i i this it was a pretty standard
auditioning process there wasn't
anything
you know interesting or exciting about
it i got an email from my agent
i read the breakdown i absolutely fell
in love
with their description of the movie and
with the sides i thought they were just
incredible and i got to see so many
different versions of the same character
from
this day one of this audition so oh of
course i saw the names attached and i
was like oh man this is so out of my
league there's no way i'm getting this
role
um but i put it on tape with my friend
uh who was a wonderful help
completely forgot about it just to
protect my own sanity
and then about four weeks later i got a
call from my agent letting me know that
i had booked the part
and to be honest with you i thought he
had the wrong number
still to this day i'm like uh are we
sure
i have a question though so you really
didn't know that you booked it like you
had no warning
until you got that phone call no none at
all i i
had forgotten about it completely i just
assumed you know i
was you know weeded out uh a while ago
um i was shocked stunned silent
if you will um when i got the call
because yeah there was no warnings no
meetings no chemistry reads no second
audition nothing
i i mean that's so not the for people
that don't understand who are watching
this that is so
not the case yeah usually you go through
like
four to five rounds of auditioning
before you book a role
it's very rare that it's uh so immediate
which is why i was like oh brian
i really think you called the wrong
actress man
uh once you booked the role i'm assuming
then you get a copy of the script
and at that moment when you see how much
you're going to be doing
are you sort of like intimidated or
extremely excited
it's so rare that an opportunity like
this comes along for an actor where you
get to play so many different versions
of the same person so i was
really really excited i mean there was
so much to just
dig my teeth into but at the same time
yeah of course i was intimidated
especially
dealing with the topics that we we cover
in this movie
you know there was a lot of
responsibility in approaching this role
and
you know the pressure to make her
likeable in the beginning so that you
care about the end of the film and the
pressure to
make sure that we're telling an honest
and true version
of this story at the end it certainly
weighed on me but
i had a wonderful group of people around
me the russo brothers had such a clear
and strong vision of what they wanted
this project to be and
tom was giving it 110 and such a
wonderful partner someone that i could
really trust and lean on in times when i
felt like
i needed that support so when it came
down to it
tackling those difficult scenes felt so
much easier because of that that group
and that foundation we had
one of the things i think that might
surprise people when they watch the
movie
are some of the filmmaking choices that
the russos make it's a very ambitious
project from the way they use the camera
to tell the story
the camera positions uh the use of slow
motion the breaking the fourth wall
i'm curious for you when you see the
movie for the first time
what was your reaction seeing what they
actually put together because it's
not like a it's not like most movies in
the way that the story is told
no it's not i mean when we were shooting
the project i i couldn't
picture it in my head i was like this
whole movie's gonna be in slow motion
like this is gonna be four hours long
but watching it
i was so impressed i mean like i said
before the brothers had such a clear
idea of what they wanted this movie to
be and while there was a lot of improv
on that i'm sure you've heard the story
of our dp tom siegel like picking up a
magnifying glass
prop and putting it up against the lens
and looking at it and he's like okay and
he taped
a prop to the front of the lens and used
it in the next shot
which you see in some of the beginning
of dope life
um but they knew what they wanted this
movie to be
and it was so clear while we were
working it was just i didn't have the
imagination to picture it yet
but sitting down and watching the movie
for the second time i had a hard time
looking the first time because i
hate watching myself but second go-round
i was so
impressed with their work and just
completely blown away with their
imagination
and what they were able to accomplish i
put on twitter that i was going to talk
to you and one of the
questions that multiple people asked was
if you could talk about the significance
of the white ribbon
that your character has yeah i think
obviously it's just her it's her
trademark in the beginning but then i
think it develops into more of
a symbolism of innocence at least for me
anyways
um something that becomes really
important to her and of course you
notice she loses it
towards the end of the film and we end
up using it for
for other other reasons so i just saw it
as sort of a symbol of innocence
uh i really enjoyed henry jackman's
score
for the for uh your character and for
uh for for the with the two of you like
your love theme if you will
uh what was your reaction actually
hearing that because it's a great piece
of music
it's stunning i think that a movie is
only as good as its score
i truly believe that truly truly i think
music
completely changes the viewing
experience and
i think he did a wonderful wonderful job
with this movie it's a truly remarkable
piece of work
do you have like do you have some
favorite scores that you listen to again
and again
um no i wish i did i wish i had a good
answer for that
i really don't soundtracks yeah i i have
got a few that i
keep coming back to time and time again
but um
i mean i'll take soundtracks too if
there's if there's a soundtrack
um okay soundtracks honestly the scott
pokem versus the world one
is very good yeah right absolutely and
then
also um adventureland
oh greg matola yeah
yeah uh i also recommend daft punk's
tron legacy
is daft punk who just split up yeah how
are you feeling today
actually right well this interview is
not about me
but they were together for sorry to
waste your time right now this isn't
they were together for almost 30 years
and they made amazing music
and 30 years is a long time i have no
idea it was that long wow it's
extraordinary
okay i'll definitely i'll give that a
listen daft punk tron legacy
i promise it's amazing um so
uh one of the things about this you have
to portray
what it's like being high on oxycontin
and heroin and and that's really to make
it believable on screen
it's like a real challenge talk a little
bit about how you got ready to film
those scenes and if you felt any
additional pressure to sort of
depict it as accurately as you can of
course i felt a lot of pressure like i
was saying before it's a huge
responsibility to tell this story and i
wanted to make sure that i was doing
emily's journey justice and i wanted to
make sure that it was believable for
people who had actually been through
that experience
so they could connect in it to the story
in a way that
hopefully lets everybody know that you
know they're not alone
um but i i wanted to make sure i was
doing my research properly
properly and i was lucky enough to have
a friend uh connecting with a family
member who works at a rehab facility in
in cleveland and they were kind enough
to open up their doors to me and i
i spoke to a lot of the people the
outpatients there who
felt comfortable sharing their story and
a lot of the employees who had gone
through the program themselves
and were recovering addicts and
listening to their insight um and
sharing these
intimate details you know things that
you really only know if you've gone
through it yourself
from the way that you look at yourself
in the mirror to
the way that people treat you at the
different stages of your addiction
different you know thought spirals and
and habits that you pick up along the
way
also like things like what it feels like
to
um um tweak to be you know
tweaking because that's something that
like that information just isn't
available online
them sharing all of that with me their
vulnerability
i cannot express to you how grateful i
am for it because i would not have been
able to do
half the job that i did on this movie
without their help and without their
generosity
there's some really fun stuff with you
guys falling in love but there's also
some really heavy stuff
and i'm curious what is it like at the
end of the day trying to like decompress
after you are portraying some
hard-hitting stuff
and then trying to figure out like go
back to who you are to go back to set
the next day
right that's like a whole new skill set
within itself that i had to develop i
mean i
i have played um characters who have
gone to some dark places
before but never quite in this way and
for so long so
you know i feel lucky that one the
brothers created a really safe
atmosphere on set where i felt
supported and i felt comfortable going
to the places that i needed to go to
because i knew that the people around me
the crew and the other cast members tom
um would help bring me back to a safe
and healthy place
and we also really prioritized
i'm call it family time if you will you
know going to get dinner together
afterwards
grabbing drinks um just a way to
to decompress and sort of process the
day that we
have just had so that we can build up
the mental clarity and strength to keep
moving forward and going to the places
that we would have to in the future
uh i'm a big fan of jack raynor uh who's
in the movie with you guys
and i'm just curious how often were you
making him talk about sing street
when you were on set i um i know mark
mckenna who's also in sing street
we are very very very very close so i
have heard
all of the stories it was just nice to
get another person's perspective i'm
such a fan of that movie
oh it's so incredible yeah listen i
could spend all
i i love that film just love we'll have
to find another time to sit down and
talk about it because i could go on all
day
you know i i could too for anyone
watching this interview is not seeing
singh street please watch it add it to
the list cherry
sing street exactly uh so i believe you
have two other projects coming up uh
small engine repair
and post uh and i don't even know what
else you might be shooting this year so
what can you tease about
some of the other things you're working
on and what are you hoping to shoot this
year
i'm really excited for you guys to get
the chance to see small engine repair
that's another movie that's very close
to my heart so i hope it can find a
a home so that everyone gets a chance to
enjoy it soon
of course that's very difficult in these
these times but
we're keeping our fingers crossed that
someone falls in love with it so that we
can distribute it to everyone else in
the world
i've also got i hate to sound so cliche
i've got one other thing coming down the
pipeline but i'm not allowed to talk
about it yet
but i am really excited about the
opportunity uh
to share it with you once i can you'll
be the first i understand
so you basically you have booked a
project that is filming later
this year that has not been announced
yet exactly
i have never encountered that with
actors i've spoken to
a first time right this is absolutely
the first time am i going to be super
angry that i didn't know about it or
just
angry i think you'll just be regular
angry
i i completely get it um one last thing
though it is really cool
in this during the pandemic for movies
like this to be on apple where people
can just watch it
you know is it sort of nice not having
to worry about like
the opening weekend box office that you
can sort of just like put the movie out
there
yeah i mean i guess i'm not really sure
what that feels like because i've never
really been in a movie
that's gone to theaters before but uh
yeah
i think it's nice i also just like the
accessibility of having it on a platform
like apple tv plus so that you know
people who aren't able to make it to a
movie theater safely
um are still able to enjoy the film at
home on that note i gotta go i'm just
gonna say
next time we'll talk more about saint
street and other stuff
thank you for your time i look forward
to it thanks steve have a good rest of
your day